[Music]
big team battle is ecology Modern
Warfare's 64 player mode but they've
said they can go up to a hundred they've
been going in this direction for a while
so they you know in black ops four they
prove they could do big maps they prove
they could do vehicles and I think it
was a matter of time before they either
I don't know like got better at Battle
Royale or just took a big ol bite out of
battlefield territory and it seems like
that's where they've headed yeah
honestly I feel like this mode they
managed to bring it back to like that
classic called a duty feel that we like
and make it feel fresh without it ever
losing that charm there's a lot of
things that they've done to move into
these larger scale maps but there's also
systems that they haven't taken from
other games that have been doing this
for a while such as like a better
spotting system or like a better paying
system like apex is ping system should
what's possible yes right and and for
this game to not have any ability for
you to call out to other teammates other
than on Mike what's happening like where
you through where you want to go like
what you see those things can make it
tricky to coordinate yeah that many
players especially when not everyone has
Mike or not everyone's even comfortable
with talking something as small as a
ping system opens that up tremendously
but I can see both sides of the coin I
can see how I would love that any day of
the week hands down but on the other
side of it
32 people all pinging something at the
same time imagine how that's gonna look
on the screen just little notifications
all over the place so I think with it
definitely being a beta they also have
to keep in mind just how many people are
in there at once and that's a really
good point they have to balance things
like kill streaks for that many people
being on a map because does it really
make sense for a UAV to always be up but
for there to always be a Harrier you
know flying down the middle of the map
it does sound really cool you know
hearing those gun runs constantly but
yeah I think it feels like they need to
they need to work on killstreaks and
whether you earn them as quickly or like
how you earn them in this mode cuz
they're just constant in everywhere I
think the counter to that is everyone
playing a role
carry around that rocket launcher 24/7
having a few members constantly being a
sniper on Lookout you know a few people
carrying spotter grenades while other
people are carrying smoke give you the
ability to coordinate team play a little
bit alright maybe have people go into
matchmaking and like League of Legends
they choose their role that was another
thing I actually really liked about
ground war was taking a little solo man
mission off to the you know behind enemy
lines just to build a spawn point that
wasn't keeping us oppressed in the back
definitely
so one of the biggest problems in the
core modes over this beta I think was
predictability or unpredictability
particularly in like spawning and spawn
flipping so you would be fighting your
way across the map and then you're just
suddenly getting doomed from behind yeah
where you spawn right into a sight line
of somebody else and just die right away
Rayo choose my swan and then all of us
I'm in crossfire and I'm dead and I'm
like where I would usually be man these
spawns are so broken now I'm like I
brought that on myself I should have
just spawned somewhere a little safer it
makes you think like it's very tempting
to want to always be in the action and
it sucks sometimes because you don't
want to spend all that time running back
in but to be safe and to actually like
have a chance of staying alive I felt
like that was something that was more
important and it made me think about
spawning a lot differently you had a lot
more options too for example I spent a
lot of time on the ridge in a tank or an
armored personnel carrier oh my gosh
this is the I mean they really they've
they've taken that sort of patented
meticulous thought about sight lines and
they've put it onto a large map I think
it's just a really excellent adaptation
of the Call of Duty formula to larger
Maps and that's what has me so excited
about playing more of this mode big team
battle and if they do add more players
that is just gonna be insane but I think
I might enjoy the 50 player mode and
this is coming from somebody who you
know ground war big team battle that's
not really my thing
like I like something a little bit more
controlled gun fight
I was in love with that mode like even
in past Call of Duty search-and-destroy
it's one of my favorite modes which is a
total 180 from ground worm but if I take
away what I like from those games and
don't go into ground were thinking that
ground wear has a lot to offer it really
is almost like a training ground I feel
like - like that's a crash course of
things you should know as someone
playing you know this type of a PS game
in general all right well that was a
quick overview of ground war so we're
really looking forward to getting our
hands on a Call of Duty further so stay
tuned a game spot and press f to pay
respects to battlefield
you